this isn't good news for dr flip flop
fauci a majority of americans now
believe
that covert 19 originated in that lab
according to a new trafalgar group
uh convention of states poll and today
over at msdnc
fauci got really pissed off very
defensive
even indignant tried to claim any
criticism of him
is a criticism of science no
just the opposite take a look
it's very dangerous chuck because a lot
of what you're seeing
as attacks on me quite frankly are
attacks on science
because all of the things that i have
spoken about consistently from the very
beginning
have been fundamentally based on science
sometimes those things were inconvenient
truths
for people and there was pushback
against me
so if you are trying to do you know get
at
me as a public health official and a
scientist
you're really attacking not only dr
anthony fauci you're attacking science
here with more louisiana senator john
kennedy senator
on january 31st 2020 dr fauci got an
email
suggesting that there's evidence that
the genome was tampered with
in a in a human in a laboratory that
altered this virus
and then there were a lot of cya emails
uh oh did we fund this was it gainer
gain and function research i think
they're very damning
sean every time i've asked i'm asked
about dr fauci i say the same thing i
know dr fauci i like dr
fauci i respect dr fauci
but dr faucia needs to cut the crap
this isn't about dr fauci it's not about
his feelings and i'm sorry if his
feelings were hurt
you know maybe he ought to buy an
emotional support pony
but but we're not debating dance moves
on tick tock here
we're talking about millions of human
lives and here's what we know
dr fauci gave a lot of u.s taxpayer
money
to the wuhan lab for chinese scientists
to research bat coronaviruses
neither dr fauci nor any of his people
can guarantee us
that the chinese scientists didn't use
that money to do gain of function
research and turn a a normal virus into
a supercharged virus
they weren't monitored dr faucini's
people didn't monitor the lab
and it's not like it hasn't happened
before since 1992
there have been 11 different experiments
widely reported in which scientists
throughout the world and labs throughout
the world have taken a normal virus
and turned it into a supercharged
pathogen
number two the the biosecurity and this
is in terms of the lab leak the
biosecurity at the wuhan lab sucked
we know that from american intelligence
and china has a history of lab leaks
1977 2004 2019.
um also since day one dr fauci and
and his uh expert friends uh have told
us look
the virus occurred naturally it jumped
from a bat to it through an intermediate
host into human beings
well it's been a year where's the proof
where's the smoking bat
do you really think if china could prove
that this virus occurred naturally in
nature
that it would withhold that evidence no
it would be screaming it from the
rooftop
to get the world off its back and final
point
there was an article this weekend on the
wall street journal by berkeley
professor
dr stephen quay and no one's talking
about it but dr quay
said look if you take the fingerprint
from the genome change that turned
the bat coronavirus into the
supercharged
cobot 19 virus and compare that
fingerprint
to the fingerprints of the 11
supercharged viruses that i just talked
about that have been created since 1992
it's the same fingerprint
maybe coincidence but dr fauci needs to
address
it and he needs to hit these things head
on otherwise
it's going to undermine public health
people's confidence in public health
and the american people are going to end
up trusting dr
pepper more than dr fauci i think that's
going to be the line of the night i
don't think you can top it but i agree
with you
and how sad is it that we now learned
from the cleveland clinic
no point vaccinating those who've had
coven 19
that if you if you had the virus you
don't get any additional benefit from
vaccination and again
he didn't listen to that science but
senator you're doing a great job for the
people of louisiana we wish you the best
in your reelection
your race is very important to the u.s
senate thank you for being with us